this morning we're very lucky to have
the shadow Home Secretary Yvette Cooper
with us this morning
um hello to you Ms Cooper thanks for
joining us I'm sure you're aware of this
story
um what should happen are the government
well within their rights to start
clawing back the money that was overpaid
well the government needs to be
responsive and the whole work and
pension system needs to be responsive to
the pressures that people face they need
to have systems in place that they can
you know actually adapt and respond
quickly so you know very often I think
we do have cases where people can
challenge the the decisions that work
and pensions department has made and
find that that then takes months that
nobody gets back to them and that is
really difficult it's really unfair in
the middle of a cost of living crisis
we've obviously got concerns as well
expectations people talking about the
bank of England raising rates today
that's also going to have an impact on
people's mortgages and people are
already paying the price on their
mortgages from the decisions that the
conservative government took last Autumn
as well so the cost of living crisis is
continuing the government has to make
sure that it's responding to that but
miss Cooper it's not the claimant's
fault that they were overpaid by the
government and now that's being clawed
back at the most challenging of times
for many of them I'm asking you this
morning should labor ask hmrc to pause
these deductions immediately and
potentially to write off that debt given
that the people that have benefited from
it it wasn't their fault
we do think that the government needs to
be more responsive and that means across
the board that means recognizing the
pressures that families are under and
making sure that they do respond quickly
and look at individual cases and do make
sure that they are not operating in an
unfair way at a time that is making
pressure worse for people
so are you saying that they people
should still pay the money back I'm not
quite sure what you're saying
look overall the the government has to
make sure that the system works and has
to make sure that that payments are made
accurately but look they shouldn't be
yours you're right they shouldn't be
making these overpayments that are their
fault in the first place and they should
also be making making sure that the way
in which they then respond to this
doesn't make things worse for people and
I've had cases in my constituency where
the government has made things worse for
people sometimes we've been able to
successfully appeal that sometimes we've
been able to get them to respond and
sometimes they haven't so we do think
the government does need to be much more
responsive and recognize the pressures
that families are under right now
especially for pressures that they might
have themselves created by their own
errors and mistakes the Prime Minister
has earned four million pounds in the
last three years quite properly and
rightly declared all of his tax returns
yesterday some say it was a good day to
bury bad news but that goes to a bygone
era um are you content with what we've
seen
well you're right that Rishi sunak did
obviously decide to choose the middle of
a very busy news afternoon in order to
publish his tax returns and the reason
we know that he's come to this point in
the first place was because obviously of
The Rao about
um the non-doms tax status in his family
and real concern that you know he should
be making sure that his household is
also abiding by the same tax rules as
everybody else across the country I
think the The Wider challenge here is
that you've got this cost of living
crisis really being faced by everyone
and the government has chosen now to
have a tax cut for the richest one
percent in the country this pensions tax
cut that they've introduced at a time
when everybody else is paying the price
that's you know around a billion pounds
being paid on that tax cut labor thinks
that is the wrong thing to do and we
would reverse that because we just think
that's not fair a time like this when
everyone is under such pressure
okay just to clarify and you have to
think about this because obviously we'll
be replaying this time and time and time
again even when you're in government
would you declare all of your taxes all
of your tax returns dating back a decade
even when you come into power
so kirstalmers has said that the
approach that we'll take is that he as
the leader of the opposition would
declare his tax returns and also that in
government the labor prime minister
Deputy Prime Minister and Chancellor
would also do so because I think that's
about saying those who are involved in
making decisions about tax making those
crucial decisions about tax should be
transparent about their own situation
um
talk to me about Boris Johnson yesterday
he was you know he was there for almost
three hours giving his a full lengthy
evidence to the Privileges committee the
chairman of that chairperson of that
committee is Harriet Harman he made the
point during the his introduction to the
committee that he didn't feel that she
was necessarily as impartial as she
could be she should be and he put her on
the long finger was she the right person
for the job
yeah I think the standards committee
operates in in a different way I think
as Harry Harmon said as part of the
committee really people put their
politics behind at the door when they
come into the committee on standards
because it's about upholding the
standards in public life the kind of
parliamentary standards that we expect
everybody to follow look I have my own
view about Boris Johnson I think he's
always been someone who is thinks it's
one rule for him and another for
everyone else that's how he's done
everything but that's not the job of the
committee they have to be rigorous and
forensic about the evidence and about
whether or not Boris Johnson misled
Parliament I think it's right for them
to do that I'll be honest with you I
didn't watch much of the committee I saw
some of the clips from it we were
preparing yesterday for the
announcements that we're making today
which is Kia stammer is setting out
Labor's mission on crime to restore
don't worry about it
and also to to to halve violent crime
particularly to Harvard against women
and girls I wanted to make sure we got a
chance to talk about that K because I do
think it's so incredibly important so
serious for people across I always let
you air your policy when you come onto
the show as I do with all other
ministers and Shadow ministers as well
you're promising to raise confidence in
policing in the criminal justice system
as well as serious crime and solving
knife crime how are you going to do that
so we have to halve the level of serious
violence in this country that includes
Harvey knife crime and also halving
violence against women and girls so for
example it means getting neighborhood
police back on the beat working with
communities to work with young people
prevent young people getting drawn into
crime in the first place and we've set
out plans for 13 000 more neighborhood
police and pcsos on the beat and on
violence against women and girls it
means overhauling the response of the
police and criminal justice system so
that for example we have domestic abuse
experts in 999 control rooms making sure
that victims get the right response from
the very beginning we intervene early to
stop domestic abuse escalating and
specialist rape investigation units in
every Force it's shocking that we don't
have that at the moment and also
specialist rape courts to speed up
justice so that victims don't end up
just giving up on the process because
it's such a nightmare for them we've got
have that action across the board on
prevention and also tackling it I think
the conservatives have just really
walked away from action on crime they've
walked away from policing from police
standards it's been a real hands-off
approach that's letting communities down
um I know that you were copied into a
video on social media that was circling
uh yesterday I don't know if you had a
chance to see it or not it was very
worrying there's a 15 year old 15 year
old school boy black boy
um he was a he was arrested
um after he was followed while he
shopped for a shampoo he was stopped by
um two Council workers
um who were Rangers apparently they're
called
um
the video seems to show that he was
assaulted by them the police turned up
and he was handcuffed and for some time
his mum did not know where he had been
taken that boy is 15 years old
um mum wanted you to see this because
she tagged you in on Twitter your
thoughts
I think it is very serious I obviously
don't know that the full circumstances
but I am troubled and I think there are
obviously some serious questions to be
answered and I think particularly as you
said as well for parents not to know
what is happening
um when uh when a child is being
arrested in that way and so I do think
that there are obviously important
questions that need to be answered look
you have to make sure that that people
are treated fairly and that children in
particular are treated fairly and
properly and in by the police and also I
think by the the refers to community
Rangers as well so I do hope that
particularly the family involved will
get answers to those questions very
swiftly will you be asking some
questions
yes and we do hope that those questions
are answered
um okay just before I let you go
um coming off these images because I
want to ask you why you're at The
Potter's Grand today
so we're I'm here in Port Vale today and
we're here is making a speech today to
set out this Mission yeah
yes
it's uh yes and you know just Kate don't
ask me about football you can talk to Ed
about football but don't ask me about
football because
we can talk about a tackling crime we
could talk about all sorts of other
issues but don't ask me about football
you know I was going to go on to the VAR
Rule and what you thought about that
technology
but I could just make it up but I think
I don't think it would do me any good
it's good to see you thanks as always
thank you
portvale thank you and